Let's look at each of these materials in turn. The problem with the highly
reflective ball, is that you're picking up light that's reflected off of this
surface. So, you're not just looking at the surface, and seeing how the light
affects it, you're seeing how other surfaces affect it. So, this answer is no
good. This one works just fine. This wooden ball isn't really doing anything as
for reflecting other objects, it's just getting directly illuminated. So,
that answer is correct. Light bulb, oddly enough, is something that you can just
render very simply, there's not really much to it. You basically are looking at
the surface and the filament inside the light is Illuminating it. So, this
answer is also correct. Finally, this glass ball is no good because it's picking
up light contributions from other objects in the scene.